good to see you both how are you doing
today
i'm good good thank you how are you
doing
i'm doing great this guy this film was
uh and is
such a pleasure just to like absorb with
your eyes if that makes any sense like
it's beautiful
and i
i wanted to ask you two about the scene
where you are
um
learning how to dance learning how to
waltz
and you're standing there with this
massive beautiful mountain range behind
you what was that day like
well it was a special trip that that
we took to queensland and there's this
beautiful location that takes i don't
know
five five minutes or so to get to the
top of but there was
we only had a small window to shoot that
scene because jane wanted a certain
light and
yeah no i was gonna say that yeah yeah i
just like envisioned it with you but it
was just um
it was really um
it was really surreal being able to
experience that with with kirsten and
yeah i mean it's one of those moments
that
you never i'm never going to forget you
know
yeah the fact that that's captured on
film for our history and like for our
children it's just very it's very
there's something so old school about
the fact that we got to work together
again and
in a movie you know i just in a jane
campion film i
yeah always go down is probably one of
the special
pieces of film will will ever be a part
of together
was that moment sort of a a true to life
moment like kirsten how's
how's jesse when it comes to dancing he
actually when we were learning the waltz
he was like no geeks it's like i was
like oh okay
when you have a child half your brain
just goes out the window it's just like
bye especially for a mom i think it just
it's very hard
to learn things
jesse was way better he'd be like no you
gotta go one two three it's like okay
okay okay so so
did he learned it first i think and then
i you know pretended that i do it better
but actually i think jesse went better
than i did
i don't know about that
there is um a very particular kind of
intensity to the relationships in this
like everything is caught in these uh
the relationships are spoken of in these
moments that where nobody's actually
talking
um and you get to see it in everybody's
face you know kirsten when
you and benedict sort of like trade
glances you can feel almost
him kind of like hitting you
what was it like working with him in
those moments
there there's very few moments we have
together really so i had to create my
own kind of
um
self-hatred monster kind of that rose
just
he gives her a little bit and then she
spirals so
i mean just the way he trumps her with
her his artistry when she's trying to
practice the piano
the little digs he does do i often shot
alone
so i i had to create what that was for
me um but benedict and i didn't speak on
set when we were on set
and that kept i imagine that just like
helped things along in terms of yeah
just like you know the dynamic was like
there you know like we don't speak to
each other but then on the weekend we
all got together obviously like oh i'm
so sorry i'm absolute
i'm like it's okay benedict whatever you
need to do to make this world the best
it can be i'm like i'll do the same you
do you like go for it
yeah you don't want to look you don't
want to like them too much on the day
no and also we didn't
like again we had like very few
exchanges benedict tonight yeah at all
in jesse film
you you guys spend a lot of time
together you and benedict here what what
do you think that this says
um about
the idea of that like the macho ideal
this film
that's a big one um
i i that that's tough to put in a
concise way but
um
i really just want to ask you what you
think but i know that's not the way this
is supposed to go i mean
yeah it's obviously it's a uh it's
something that that phil has created
here and it's it's it's a mask and it's
something that
that is is a cover for
some deep vulnerability and
you know torment and and his own self
loathing and all of that yeah but i
think it comes in a lot of different
forms um
yeah i think that's that's a pretty big
conversation i don't know and well and
that's kind of i think essentially
that's what the movie is for to start
that conversation you know thank you so
much both of you is a pleasure chatting
with you
you